the The Next Step so first he has to
make sure she's put it in the effort
she's putting in the commitment are
there [ __ ] tests that women commonly do
early I've heard this term and I don't
think I don't know if it's
if women [ __ ] test like on purpose
because some of the stuff that I hear
guys talk about that are [ __ ] tests I
think they're kind of
on accident to us it's not on accident
it's the way you guys are designed [ __ ]
tests [ __ ] tests vary depending on the
situation if you're at a bar or club
trying to pick up a woman women [ __ ]
test you on purpose I don't date Black
guys answer oh neither do I I mean can
you imagine dude I get a laugh at that I
Gotta Laugh at that every time
um when women [ __ ] test you in that
social Pua scenario they just want to
make sure that you have experience with
women women in relationships [ __ ] tests
on [ __ ] test on autopilot This Is Not a
Bad Thing women have to [ __ ] test what
women are doing here is they're biting
the gold and women have to [ __ ] test
their men every so often to make sure
that he is still the man that that she
fell in love with
um so in relationships women [ __ ] test
on autopilot now there's a big
difference between [ __ ] tests and
disrespect if a [ __ ] if a supposed [ __ ]
test makes you feel upset or angry
that's not a [ __ ] test that's disrespect
but for men to not expect affect a woman
a woman who doesn't test a man is not
interested in a man you can welcome to a
girl and start chatting her up and blah
blah blah blah oh man she hasn't [ __ ]
test to me then you go in for the number
close and she tells you well I have a
boyfriend or well blah blah blah blah
and you're like what the hell she never
[ __ ] tested you because she never was
interested in you in the first place
women women will [ __ ] test men as a in
relationships women will indirectly [ __ ]
test men as a matter of
re-confirmation rather than
disqualification now there are
impassable [ __ ] tests at which point
your woman has already lost respect for
you the the relationship is likely going
to be over but [ __ ] tests are a good
thing if your woman if your woman is not
[ __ ] testing you in a relationship it
means one of two things either number
one you're doing it right and you don't
give her a reason to [ __ ] test you or
number two she just needs to she needs
to pinch herself a little bit and kind
of put a and and just make sure okay is
this the guy that I'm meant to be with
is this guy the same and can I have a
couple examples of a [ __ ] test that you
should break up with a girl over and a
[ __ ] test that this is how you would
handle it
a breakup with a girl over in a long
term or short-term relationship let's
say long term because I think a lot of
my audience is looking for wives more
than short-term relationships if they
want pickups
yeah
that would wow that's that's a very good
question
um what is the kind of [ __ ] test if I
were to get a [ __ ] test well here's the
thing a [ __ ] test is just that it's a
test if a [ __ ] test leads to a breakup
in a man's mind then chances are either
you are too weak to pass the [ __ ] test
and just didn't have it in you or what
she did was disrespect so a lot of girls
think that mentioning hey my ex tested
texted me today they think that's a [ __ ]
test that is not a [ __ ] test that is
disrespect if now before the
relationship you make it clearer listen
I don't commit to women who stay in
contact with people who have been inside
of them so the minute she tells you hey
my texted me my my ex my text next to me
my my ex texted me and I responded and
they've been and going back and forth
well guess what she just she just broke
up with you because she engaged in the
behavior that makes her a kind of woman
that you don't date so that's the kind
of quote-unquote [ __ ] test that will end
the relationship her putting herself her
wanting to put your relationship your
supposed relationship at risk and
telling you about it that's not a [ __ ]
test that's disrespect yeah that was my
um
thought as well was if she's like hey
I'm going to I'm going out to lunch with
so and so from work male co-worker
um
uh ignore what your feelings are and I
think that's that's that is important
um when you start operating without the
consideration of the person that you
supposedly love your relationship is
over
and that's what you guys do in a lot of
your skits right you'll go through
different scenarios that maybe some men
used to put up with or that's a
situation that they've been in and and
your your message is you don't have to
accept this you can walk away so you
don't have to put women on a pedestal
right I think what most men and most men
especially in the west they have no idea
just how much more valuable they are as
people than the women they are pursuing
just because dude listen man I have
known some extremely beautiful women who
are extremely low value people yeah
they're cool and they're cool to hang
out with and do drugs with and all and
all this other kind of stuff but they
don't have a pot to piss in they're
crass they act like men a lot of them
dropped out of high school they're just
they're just trash people
um and and it's funny it's it the more
attractive a woman is I'm trying to tell
you I've been through I've been through
enough attractive women to know and
understand this to be 100 true the more
attractive of a woman is the less
valuable she tends to be the more of an
attitude she tends to have the more
entitled she tends to be the more she
tends to nag because attractive women
get the benefit of the doubt and
attractive women live the attractive
women in the United States in the west
they live the best lives of any class of
human on the planet regardless of their
behavior that's just how this is Amber
Heard is really the first attractive
woman who has ever been taken to task
over the [ __ ] behavior that she put
a man through only because she tried the
okie doke on him but if you're expecting
an attractive woman to just fall in line
because you think she's a good person
because she's attractive you're gonna
have another thing coming
there's a comment that said should a
woman have any male friends
she can have listen should a woman have
any male friends in terms of what a
relationship yeah in a relationship I
mean a woman is entitled to see what I
guess what he needs to I guess the
question really is should I accept the
fact that my long-term girlfriend has
male friends the answer is no you should
not accept that the only exceptions are
if her male friend is gay
um her hair no seriously one of her one
of her hairdressers his name was Travis
dude coolest dude coolest guy in the
world if Devin wanted to go and hang out
with him and all that listen go knock
yourself out
um but that's the only exception um male
friends are um male friends now here's
the thing you cannot tell your woman
what she can or cannot do you can't do
that you can't control women nor should
you seek to control them but what you
can do is you can control your behavior
so when guys ask well is having male
friends acceptable well only if you
accept it if you make yourself scarce if
you let your woman know through your
words and actions hey look if you have
male friends that's cool we're just
gonna keep casual if we're in a
committed relationship and all of a
sudden you start befriending males guess
what it's going to it's going to devolve
from a long-term relationship to uh uh
to something casual that's all there is
to it you don't have to [ __ ] you don't
have to fight you don't have to argue if
she engages in activities that put your
relationship at risk just downgrade the
relationship no problem at all
and so that's why it's so important to
have that up front your expectations
right
yeah absolutely and do you think a lot
of guys are afraid to say that up front
because of things like feminism and like
the modern of course I don't like dude I
mean like back when back when I actually
read the comments in in the chat and all
that you see women anytime I mention
anytime I mention that you know you have
to protect a woman from herself oh my
God you're toxic and this and that in
the third guys see this stuff and so
when they get into relationships of
their own or interactions with women on
their own they're like well I don't want
to be toxic I don't want to be insecure
I don't want to be I don't want to be
jealous I don't want to be you know
considered to be one of these possessive
boyfriends so that that really sort of
nips that in the bud never be afraid as
a man to set boundaries if if she does
not allow you to set boundaries dude no
sweat off your back simply downgrade the
relationship to casual or just a
one-time fling and keep it moving that's
all you got to do you can't control
women man